le gouvernement trudeau refuse de
s'engager à ne pas aider les entreprises
canadiennes qui ont des activités dans
les paradis fiscaux
l'engagement de son gouvernement c'est
d'aider les travailleurs d'abord et
avant tout andré lareau et professeur
associé à la faculté de droit de
l'université laval bonsoir monsieur
lareau bonsoir il ya des pays comme le
danemark et la pologne qui refuse
d'aider les entreprises enregistrées
dans des paradis fiscaux
est ce que le canada pourrait faire ça
le canada pourrait certainement le faire
la volonté tels la gent de clés les
gouvernements de copains d'europe et
même auparavant jean chrétien
maintenant le sud trudeau les gens ont
l'information ils le savent et sociétés
canadiennes sont beaucoup dans les
paradis fiscaux et il faut rien il vaut
rien s que c'est pas le temps maintenant
de coups de barre 250 millions de la vie
milliards de déficit d'ici là est-ce que
c'est pas le temps de donner un coup de
barre août ajoutée environnementale que
fiscal est ce que de 15 n est pas si on
ne saisit pas cette occasion là pour
changer les choses
jamais on ne saisit pas je vais enfin qu
bougera jamais quoi que ce soit donc il
faut faire des choses vous avez des
milliards de dollars il ya 350 milliards
de dollar et nécessita des canadiens
dans douce atifi ce coup là or ces gens
là qui dans une société que dans les
paradis fiscaux c'est pour pour elle à
la plage en 2d et on aurait pu utiliser
d'autres pays que les paradis fiscaux
bon social de paradis fiscaux que ce
soit pour du financement
que ce soit pour des opérations que ce
soit pour la propriété intellectuelle
tout ça se trouve dans les paradis
fiscaux il ya des milliards de dollars
à preuve on a qu'à voir un jugement
rendu la semaine dernière le conseil
fédéral dans la sphère de l'aube la
halle aux bleds compagnie canadienne
mille quatre cent mille quatre cent
cinquante millions $ crédit et qui va
échapper au fisc et d'asier prône aussi
de la barbade le gouvernement at il
prévu par ailleurs des mécanismes pour
vérifier si les particuliers les
entreprises qui bénéficient des
différents programmes dead en ont
vraiment besoin
malheureusement les législations qui ont
été créés dans la cadre des mesures
d'urgence ne prévoit pas du tout mes
yeux de récupération somme ce qu'on fait
on prend une photographie du
contribuable ou de la société qui
demande la subvention par exemple
salariale le contribuable le ccu et on
dit voilà aujourd'hui ce que tu
satisfait aux conditions si la réponse
est oui
c'est la fin de l'histoire et puis vous
aurez droit à la somme mais qu'est ce
qui se passe si à la fin de l'année le
contribuable ou la société mère fois la
société la santé financière est bien
meilleur que ces élections anticipées
n'ont aucune révision des situations
alors qu on a qu'à comparer avec
l'assurance emploi ou la prestation de
la sécurité de la vieillesse qui font
l'objet de récupération fiscale
lorsqu'avec timar la situation
s'embellit or ici rien n'est prévu mais
les et c'est malheureux parce qu'il ya
bien des gens des sociétés qui dans
n'ont pas besoin est ce que des gens qui
gagnent 150 200 mille dollars peu
importe le par année ont vraiment besoin
en temps d'une aide d'urgence au
lendemain on est dans l'outrance 16
heures est-ce que tu as de l'argent pour
payer son loyer la nourriture des
besoins essentiels
cela répond si oui clé moi c'est réponse
est oui j'évite les gens qui en ont
profité à faire des dons de charité l
effet de nous de remettre l'argent
l'argent du revenu parce que question de
moralité fiscale
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on donnerait une
moralité vous avez raison mais est ce
qu'on devrait faire un changement
législatif au moment de la déclaration
de revenus par exemple l'an prochain le
changement législatif il sera trop tard
pour obliger les gens qui ont perçu des
sommes aujourd'hui ne passant pas
qu'elle débatteurs une récupérer je
pense pas que le changement législatif
serait très à propos il soit trop tard
les gens doivent aujourd'hui avant
l'heure juste est ce que la somme que je
reçois je devrais la remettre oui ou non
et donc le changement les jt c'est bon
de le faire dès maintenant pour les
paiements à venir
sinon il trop tard mais ce qui est
quelque chose qu'on devrait changer que
vous suggérez barre en fait on devrait
avoir vu la formule de récupération qui
va perdre y être que le gouvernement
puisse récupérer donc se faire
rembourser dans la prochaine déclaration
d'impôts de méfaits qui sera fait en
les sommes perçues dans la mesure où le
portrait financier du contribuable
démontre qu'il n'y avait pas d'urgence
et qui donne une chance pour les faits
annuel
l'effet financière annuelle du
contribuable et puis si c'était le cas
ben ma foi que la déclaration des ponts
vient de récupérer la somme vous savez
les plusieurs anachronisme nappe toutes
les pressions d'urgence et subventions
salariales
pourquoi par exemple les scans employés
qui doit la pcu reçoit 500 par semaine
l'appréciation de l'urgence 1147 par
semaine
si je suis employé ne pas propre société
je pourrais recevoir 847 par semaine
c'est ma propre société dont je suis le
seul employé comme garçons 847 par
semaine si c'était pas incorporé jaurès
rsa pourquoi l'écart ouest aller vite
c'est ça qui est ça qui arrive et on est
très vite dans l'urgence on est allé
très vite cessé d'y et bien sûr on avait
des choses à faire il faut il faut faire
le ménage et reprendre comme je les ai
raison merci beaucoup monsieur l'hérault
mais c'est à voir